pilot the [ __ ] Bombardier pilot
to Bombardier
I don't see anything I see nothing but
clouds I can't see oh my god
you
namaste [ __ ] uncle Joey here
coming back to you we just want to call
this the [ __ ] cloud look this is
exactly what it is it's cloudy when you
know what gives a Frenchman's [ __ ] I'm
gonna add some more [ __ ] clouds on
burning cue Melinda's coming out of this
[ __ ] pipe this morning I said it once
I said it again whoo you ain't got no
heart going to closet hanging yourself
the understan Victor's heart it's what
it's all about ain't got nothing to add
to this [ __ ] world you understand me
I never did never have never will
but I got one thing I'll leave forever
my [ __ ] heart but you got to shoot me
in the head with a [ __ ] bazooka I
just don't give a [ __ ] and if your
mentality isn't like that it's not
hanging out at Starbucks not hanging out
with these [ __ ] [ __ ] friends don't
wanna see we'll see [ __ ] get back to
basics it's all about heart and I put
heart into everything I [ __ ] do
whether it's smoking this [ __ ] pipe
while going up in that stage of my that
little [ __ ] odd about the heart
attack I don't give a [ __ ]
sometime you're right now you're [ __ ]
your dad to drop on you today is a high
in this damn example you don't walk
around and [ __ ] barbecue coals if
you've got a [ __ ] hard you don't fall
for this [ __ ] that most of these asset
was thoughtful but you see you got a
hard surface now enough with the
chitty-chat and let's go out there the
burden I got some tremendous Reese's I
got a perennial old G for getting BR
this is just too much piastre has the
Puerto Rican and I got the blue rookies
a sativa with a [ __ ] hybrid kick to
it and I'm not your [ __ ] dick in a
different a person up Joe spark that
soul
look at look at that that's not the
police's breathing exercises along with
the [ __ ] tree trunk you think I'm
gonna give you a bad [ __ ] of
information I'll put Joey don't play
that [ __ ]
I'm gonna Vegas I'm gonna see my main
man talking they're liable to watch when
I pick up my D as when it's will a smoke
more reefer smoke more really relate to
thousand stars that I'm doing this show
we're open to have you're in Vegas
I'll see you they have not I don't know
what the [ __ ] that tight let's do this
blue cookies melt this is a weed I had
in my car for his for 14 days
I bought a gram for a friend of mine I
went to the doctor I smoked it design
that's the only weed I had in the car
and I got [ __ ] up so what you bought
an aether it does it's tough to get a
good [ __ ] my bridge the table
don't get diggin it there but this one I
ain't [ __ ] around when they make this
understand me [ __ ] it's Friday
he gonna get together with Joann bot
then tell these [ __ ] what time
it is
what do whatever the [ __ ] it is that you
do go to your little coffee shop but
these plans going to Turkey and saving
blind kids no the [ __ ] you want to do
but I'm telling him and you should think
of it's Friday was a great week we had a
great week together you know I love you
[ __ ] bought my heart I don't do
this [ __ ] I do I do it for you
[ __ ] cuz you crazy just like it
was gonna be a crazy where I'm gonna
[ __ ] [ __ ] up all these conventional
[ __ ] they corny ass jokes will
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up like now the album
is dead last night we're gonna rattle
the [ __ ] game you understand me
I need you [ __ ] to step up and
go you know what [ __ ] this punk-ass
[ __ ] I'm gonna pull Joey he's with me
and you will [ __ ] this wannabe with us
and that's it
I don't know what the [ __ ] tell you
[ __ ] you know they have to tell
you that I love you
and I love that we can be spent this
little time together like family the
rest of these [ __ ] RV almost let's go
to a show that [ __ ] that this is it us
on periscope get my head together that
was them to the people of Daoist have a
great state of Texas what's going on
there but you know what man it's gonna
happen black people that just take so
much you know so this was but I've seen
those videos from this week and there's
something going on this country just
dissing right on that political activist
I'm not here to drop jokes I'm just here
to state my [ __ ] case caucus but
nothing enough it's not a little briefer
and Paul the day this is about us today
is about us having a good time get
together
leave in the [ __ ] you know I'm not
gonna send you out there amongst the
[ __ ] wolf young-sam I want you to be
mentally prepared for these [ __ ]
may come up here whatever with the fun
selling you whatever the magic they have
you could look at them and say medical
Joey told me about [ __ ] [ __ ]
like you
take your magic elsewhere top succomb
know what man all lives matter
[ __ ] all lives matter I'm sick
at all rights matter
those cops had families their daughters
their sons and cats their dogs all lives
matter
little kids [ __ ] kids people are
[ __ ] up all lives matter since let's
topic that should have ready every
[ __ ] life matters that little bubble
around the wall he's here for [ __ ]
reason
[ __ ] don't illegals I'll see
you tonight Omaha's Vegas if I don't
have a great weekend we're doing a
podcast Sunday night I go to surgery
Monday morning so we won't be having
these will take days let me have no much
straws coming out of my nose but you
guys won't live you don't want to come
back stronger and that's it you know I
love you guys remember and I'm not deaf
I'm not gonna shoot yourself for some
point out with other people ain't got no
hard feeling ever gonna get nowhere at
the end they are you make well I saw
that beating yellow milk when I saw if I
bring her ayah back a little sip I don't
wanna go on it get metal giving oh it
broke down me better on carping I said
it so I'm telling you right now I
strongly about my booked under she to a
point for that some of it I see a lawyer
matter thinking father but you know I
went off I said yes wanna go with it
that I don't care see understand I'm
saying it you got your little Cuban
minute look there may in my opinion what
about Bingham and throw a liar
I love you [ __ ] I see you
tomorrow tomorrow we'll do a little
number maybe we'll smoke about blood
solution from Las Vegas time we'll tap
that all right I didn't forget about you
stay black now with Joey loves your
fascia from no [ __ ] I talk all the
sudden you dick